Is it true that the electricity you resell,
I am more of a supplier,
no but no,
but that you were doing,
go to those who,
those who are always suppliers,
Here it is, P.
This electricity at a certain price,
50 €42,
€42?
Yes
but how much does he resell it?
Uh,
in terms of tariffs regulate electricity
2 EDF regulated by the state,
more or less X percent depending on the bones that make
hold. Yes?
But how much?
How much do they sell?
on average
on average,
the baker
who makes total energy and who has seen his bill
multiplied by 10,
how much?
But he saw his bill multiplied by 10?
Whether it is with a fictional supplier or with EDF,
you know that, right?
Mr. EDF too.
If you are not at the regulated rate,
yes yes,
but if you are at the EDF market,
at least it produced,
but how much?
1 baker who has seen his bill increase by 10,
the you pay €40 for 70% of the energy,
right?
Whether you provide
70565656 70% of the energy you resell
and you bought it for €40,
How much do you sell it?
That's a simple question,
Bourdin gives it to you,
and when you have invoices that are times 10×15
since last year,
how much? No, tell us